- See, most people want it easy.
See, easy come, easy what?
Easy go.
What if you live your whole life
only to discover that it was wrong?
That it was wrong?
What would your life be like,
as you look toward the future,
if you decided,
"I'm not going to allow
my fears to stop me"?
- He's one of the world's most renowned
motivational speakers.
He mastered the science of achievement
by interviewing hundreds of
successful business leaders
over three decades.
He received the Golden Gavel Award
for Achievement and
Leadership in Communication.
He's Les Brown,
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success,
volume two.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Also as you are writing something down,
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy.
(paper airplane swooshes)
(inspirational music)
- Here's what I discovered
that happens to your life,
that you will go through things,
and while you're going through them,
you can't understand why
it's happening to you.
But after you go through it,
you get back and you look at it,
and you say, "Oh, now I understand
"why I needed that lesson."
Have you ever had it happen to you?
Raise your hand.
Has it ever happened to you?
(scattered applause)
That I couldn't understand it then,
but after I got through it,
then I saw that that was preparing me
for bigger and better things.
(applause)
That as you go through
the challenges of life,
and you look at it and
embrace whatever comes to you,
don't run from it.
Step toward it.
Don't try and duck it like most people do.
See, most people want it easy.
See, easy come, easy what?
Easy go.
See, but when you go at what
you're going to deal with
and you deal with the difficulties of it,
when you handle those
hard things close at hand,
making those hard decisions right now
that you don't want to make,
learning those things
that you don't like to do,
but you know that in order for you
to get where you want to go,
this is one of the hoops that
you have to flip through.
And I'm saying to you,
whatever you got to do, do it,
because if you don't,
life is going to whoop you
until you surrender and say,
"Okay, all right, all
right, all right, all right.
"I'll cooperate, okay.
"I'll learn, okay."
It had to wear me out a long time.
So if it's hard, then do it hard.
You're going to focus
to develop your skills.
A guy was, was um,
the new owner of a team,
a baseball team that was in
the basement of the league
when he took it over.
He went to the pitcher
and he said, "What is your best throw?"
And he said, "Well, I got a good curveball
"and I've got a good fastball."
And he went on talking
about his different throws.
He said, "But tell me this.
"What is your best throw?"
He thought for a moment.
He said, "I've got a good fastball."
He said, "That's all
I want you to work on.
"Nothing else.
"Just develop your fastball."
The next year, they went
to the World Series.
Most people don't know
what their fastball is.
Most people go through life
never discovering what their talents are.
Most people never develop their talents.
They have skills and abilities,
but if you don't nurture them,
if you don't develop them,
they will never serve you.
Your gifts can take you many places
if you develop your gifts.
Most of us don't like to do
those things that come easy to us.
I've always loved to talk to people.
I decided, taking this advice,
to develop my skills as a speaker,
and my gift has developed and developed
and has taken me many places.
You have something that you
brought to the universe,
and that if you decide that my life
deserves my developing
this, what I do well,
and becoming the best at
it and mastering myself
and seeing what I have within me.
If you decide to drop
your buckets where you are
and develop your gifts,
I grant you you'll never ever be without.
I grant you your gifts
will take you places
that will literally amaze you.
I grant you that if you begin
to work to develop your gifts,
you'll develop a strong
sense of happiness.
You'll get a larger vision of yourself,
because part of beginning to get
a larger vision of yourself,
all of us need some area of our lives
where we can have a feeling of competence.
People know when they
think about this area,
that's something you do.
That you eat and sleep that.
And that you do that.
You do that.
And people know it.
And you know it,
and you know that you
know that you know this.
If you don't know anything
else, you know this.
(laughter)
Can you tell I know I know what I'm doing?
Ah, hello. (laughs)
You know this.
So you've got to work on it.
Dr. Howard Thurman,
one of the mentors of Dr.
Martin Luther King, Jr.
and Albert Schweitzer and Mahatma Gandhi.
He was a very brilliant writer.
He wrote some things
that really grabbed me.
He wrote "Deep is the Hunger,"
"The Voice of the Genuine,"
"The Centering Moment."
During the time after receiving
238 radiation seed implants,
I was reflecting on his words,
and these words kept me up that night.
He said, "The ideal situation
for a man or woman to die
"is to have family
members praying with them
"as they cross over."
He said, "But imagine if you
will, being on your deathbed,
"and standing around your bed,
"the ghost of the dreams,
"the ideas,
"the abilities,
"the talents given to
you by life and that you,
"for whatever reason, you
never went after that dream,
"you never acted on those ideas,
"you never used those talents,
"you never used those gifts.
"And there they are
standing around your bed,
"looking at you with
large, angry eyes, saying,
"We came to you,
"and only you could have
given us life, and now
"we must die with you forever."
(crowd murmurs)
And the question is,
if you died today,
what dreams,
what ideas,
what talents, what books,
what music, what leadership,
what voice will die with you?
Myles Munroe, great orator and speaker,
said the wealthiest place on the planet,
it's not in the Far East where
there's oil in the ground,
it's not in South Africa
where there are diamond mines.
He said, "The wealthiest place
on the planet is the cemetery."
Because there you'll find
greatness that we've never seen.
There you'll find talent and genius
and potential never actualized.
Perhaps that's why Henry
David Thoreau wrote the words,
"Oh God, to reach the point of death
"only to realize that you've never lived."
Maybe that's why some unknown
writer wrote the words,
"What if you live your whole life
"only to discover that it was wrong?"
That it was wrong.
That you were chosen to do something else,
and you didn't do it.
And as you begin to challenge yourself,
you'll discover some things about yourself
that you don't know right now.
The other thing is you
begin to look at yourself,
look at your dreams, and
begin again to experiment.
And stepping into your greatness,
one of the things that's very important,
whatever goals and dreams that you have,
repeat after me please:
"Make your move before you're ready."
- [Crowd] Make your move
before you're ready.
- Yeah, Price Pritchett,
who's a great motivator and trainer,
he said, "Make your move
before you're ready."
We're instructed in life to walk by faith
and not by sight.
So you want to really
begin to stretch yourself,
you want to become a risk taker.
You want to raise the bar on yourself.
Most people won't do that.
See, most people engage
in low life living.
Low-risk living.
This guy said, "If you're
not willing to risk,
"you cannot grow."
And if you cannot grow, you
cannot become your best.
And if you cannot become your
best, you can't be happy.
And if you can't be happy,
then what else is there?
I like what Helen Keller said.
"Life is short and unpredictable.
"Eat the dessert first."
(laughter)
And so, you want to begin
to take some chances.
You want to begin to challenge yourself
and make it okay to fail and
learn from your failures.
Don't allow
fear of failure
and the allure, the attractiveness
of playing it safe in life to draw you in.
You can't get out of life alive.
You've got to die to leave here.
There're a lot of people
who're biting their fingers
in fear that they might lose their jobs.
But there're few people who
have decided within themselves,
"I'm going to make it."
Some people aren't waiting to be cut.
Some people are moving on their own,
because they feel within themselves,
"I've got what it takes to make it."
They're not afraid about tomorrow,
because of how they see themselves,
because of what they
feel that they deserve,
because of what they feel
that they can create for themselves,
because these people have decided,
as they look at the future,
as they look at themselves,
"There's a way.
"Where there's a will, there's a way
"for me to begin to create
a way out of no way."
And when you have that
kind of consciousness,
when you have that kind of spirit,
nothing can stop you.
Nothing.
What would your life be like,
as you look toward the future,
if you decided,
"I'm not going to allow
my fears to stop me"?
What would your life be like?
What would your future be like,
if you decided
to want that which you desire so strongly
that it prepares you past your fears,
that you experience the fear,
as the one book says, "Feel
the fear, and do it anyway"?
(crowd murmuring)
What would your life be like?
And I'm saying to you that all of us
who have been entombed by fear
have the capacity to resurrect ourselves,
and to resurrect our dreams.
(applause)
All of us have the capacity to do that.
I want you to look at something right now.
Think of some major goal you want,
or maybe it's one you're
already working on
and you have experienced
a lot of setbacks,
a lot of defeats,
you've experienced a
lot of disappointment.
Maybe you've already given up.
And maybe you just need a little fire,
little encouragement to
get back in the game again.
Here's what I want you to look at.
There're winners, and there're losers,
and there're people who have
not discovered how to win.
And all they need is some coaching.
All they need is some help and assistance,
just a little support.
All they need is some insight,
or a different strategy,
a plan of action,
to make some adjustments
that will open up the key
to a whole new future for them,
that will give them access
to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves.
That's all that they need.
So what I want you to do is think about
something you want for you,
that's real for you,
that's important for you,
that will give your life some
special meaning and power.
And I don't even want you
to say, "I can do that."
I don't want you to assume that.
See, five years ago, when
I started out in this area,
I would not have been able
to make the mental leap
that I would be up to
where I am right now.
I don't want you to begin
to just psych yourself out.
No, no.
I want you to be able to
say something to yourself
that will enable you to maintain
a level of integrity with yourself.
That when you say this,
even when you face tremendous setbacks,
it will be a benchmark
to keep you in the game,
to keep you moving
forward and experimenting
and readjusting your strategy
and your plan of action,
continuously looking for ways to win.
So what is that something?
When you got an idea you want to move on,
you might not have the money,
you might not have the education,
you might not have the support
or the resources you need.
What is that something
that can keep us going,
that will enable us to act on our dreams?
What's one of those keys
that will begin to help us
to discover the secrets to our dream?
Here's what I want you to
repeat after me, please,
with power and conviction.
Say, "It's possible."
- [Crowd] It's possible.
- That's all I want you to do
when you look at your dream.
Just say to yourself every
day, "It's possible."
You say that every day to
yourself, "It's possible."
Because what does that do?
See, it begins to change
your belief system.
See, the way in which we
operate, ladies and gentlemen,
it's a manifestation of what we believe,
what's possible for us.
Whatever you've done up to this point,
all that it really is is a duplication,
it's a reproduction of what
you believe subconsciously
that you deserve and what's
possible for your life.
Before April 1954,
the common belief, the universal belief,
because it'd been tried
again and again and again
and people had failed,
the belief was that man
was not physically capable
of breaking the four-minute barrier,
that he could not run a mile
in less than four minutes.
That was the belief on the planet.
It'd never been done.
But here's what happened,
ladies and gentlemen.
Roger Bannister came along,
and he broke the four-minute barrier.
Now here's what's significant about that.
Since that time, up to this day,
over 20,000 people have done it,
including high school kids.
What changed?
20,000 people.
Here's what happened.
When they got on the track,
they knew it'd been done.
And because they knew it'd been done,
there was a new belief about this barrier,
about this goal that was unreachable.
And those 20,000 people
got in a race believing,
knowing in their heart
that someone had done it,
that's it's possible
that they could do it.
And I'm saying that if you know
anybody that had some goal,
some dream, something they wanted to do
and they did it,
then I'm saying that
you know in your heart
that if someone has done it,
then you can do it.
It's possible.
And that if someone can make
their dream become a reality,
that it's possible that you can make
your dream become reality.
If you constantly remind
yourself after every defeat,
after every setback, every
time you get knocked down,
I've got a saying,
"If life knocks you down,
try and land on your back,
"because if you can look
up, you can get up."
See, a lot of people, because of failure,
they stop, they stop believing.
Let me share something with you.
You will fail your way to success.
Yes.
Eight out of ten millionaires
have been financially bankrupt.
You will fail your way to success.
It doesn't matter how many times you fail.
It doesn't matter how many times
people tell you that you can't do it.
It doesn't matter if you
don't have a dime in the bank.
You will fail your way to success.
We live in a world where we're told
more about our limitations,
rather than our potential.
How many of you have ever been told
that you couldn't do something?
Raise your hands, please.
You know, MIT did a study
that if I say to you,
"You can't do that,"
that 16 people have to come along and say,
"You can do that, you can
do that, you can do that,"
to neutralize that,
and the 17th statement that
you hear, "You can do it,"
will be the one that will finally stick.
So, you have to watch
who's speaking into you.
You've got to begin to monitor your mind.
And you've got to begin
to literally be proactive
in programming yourself to success.
Be ye not conformed to this world.
Be ye transformed by the
renewing of your mind.
You've got to take responsibility
to make that happen.
And as you begin to do that,
you'll begin to see some
incredible changes in your life.
I understand now, when
Earl Nightingale said,
"All of us are self-made,
"but only the successful will admit it."
As you begin to look at your
dreams and look at your goals,
write this down:
"Make no your vitamin."
See, most people stop
short of their dreams
and park and get off the highway of life,
because of the rejections of life.
You will always be rejected.
It's no big deal.
Jack Canfield said, "Rejection is a myth."
It's not like when somebody says, "No,"
and then they slap you.
No, it's just, you know, to
me, make no your vitamin.
Get excited about the no.
Why? Because every time someone says no,
that brings you another step to a yes.
You're getting closer.
Trust me, you will win if you don't quit.
You will win if you don't quit.
Even a broke clock is right twice a day.
And so, as I began to work on myself,
I realized that I'm
getting out of one story
and stepping into another story.
As I become aware of some things,
there's still some
things I'm not aware of.
So I'm still growing,
I'm still developing.
I'm like the lady who said,
"Lord, I ain't what I want to
be, ain't what I'm going to be,
"but thank God, I sure ain't what I was."
But I realize that you
have to work on yourself
on a regular basis, and write this down,
"for mental mindset."
For mental mindset and stamina.
Because things are going to happen to you.
So I went to the next mode,
necessary to start talking to people
and seeking and asking for what I wanted,
and leveraging relationships
and trying to find out,
how do the people do it
that went ahead of me?
How do they do it?
And then what is I need to do?
How is it I need to train
myself, to develop myself?
What's the resources that will be required
in order to make it happen?
And as I start seeking
out and asking questions,
I start running into people said,
"I know someone who can help you do that."
And they helped me get
connected with those people.
Remember, we have so much
energy that can take us so far.
It's necessary that you hook up
with some other inner energy
that can take you to the next level.
I hooked up with them,
they said, "Les, let's go!"
I said, "Away we go!"
(laughter and applause)
And guess what?
Here we are! (laughs)
(applause)
I love it!
You want your stuff?
It's necessary you take
responsibility for it,
that you make it happen,
that you don't give up,
that you don't take any objection
or disappointment or defeats personally,
that you keep on keeping on,
that you don't decide that I can't make it
because you can't see th light
at the end of the tunnel,
that you realize that's
a part of the program.
And here's something
you've got to resolve.
Say this to yourself every day.
See, as long as you're breathing,
you got a shot at your dream.
That's the way I resolve.
Say this, please:
"It's not over ..."
- [Crowd] It's not over ...
- "until I win."
- [Crowd] Until I win.
- You got that right.
(laughter and applause)
It's not over 'til I win.
Not over 'til I get through.
It's not over 'til I get over.
Not over 'til I get what I want.
Door can't open today, look out.
I'm going to come back
and take the hinges off.
(laughter)
That's how you got to do that.
You've got to have that kind of courage,
that type of determination.
If you want to make it happen, it's you.
But you've got to take
personal responsibility
to make it happen.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video to continue
in the Volume Two series.
I'd love to know what you guys think
and if we should continue it.
If you want to nominate
somebody else, let me know.
I'd also really love to know,
what did you learn from Les today
that had the biggest
impact on you and why?
What message are you
going to take from him
and immediately apply it to your life
or your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout-out
to J-Ryze and Lynx.
Thank you guys so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, "Your One Word,"
and that entry into the contest.
I loved the video, and I
really appreciate your support.
- We're here to do a major unboxing.
- Look what I got in the mail today!
- Exciting!
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(paper airplane whooshes)
- Most people are not accumulating wealth.
Most people are living in poverty.
Most people are living
far below their potential,
not because they don't have the capacity,
not because they have not been
given authority and dominion
over everything on the face of the Earth,
but most people are
living like they're living
because of the fact
that they don't believe
they can have any more
than what they now have.
In the book called "The
Mis-Education of the Negro,"
Dr. Carter G. Woodson said,
"If you can determine
what a man shall think,
"you'll never have to concern yourself
"with what he will do.
"If you can make a man feel inferior,
"you'll never have to compel
him to seek an inferior status,
"for he will seek it himself.
"And if you can make a man
feel justly an outcast,
"you never have to order
him to go to the back door.
"He'll go without being told;
"and if there's no door, his
very nature will demand one."
That's why Scripture reminds us,
"Be ye not conformed to this world,
"but be ye transformed by
the renewing of your mind."
So every day, you have to sell yourself,
and get out of your
mind those old thoughts,
that old belief system.
Every day you've got to sell yourself
on that it's possible.
But you got to put a new mind in you.
You got to get out of your mind.
You got to begin to
restructure your thinking.
Every day, you've got to begin
to recondition your mind.
See, many of us go through
life making choices,
thinking it's our choices, and it's not.
You want to make your dream come true,
you got to stay focused.
Some people rather get
even than get ahead.
Stay focused on where you want to go.
I just kept on doing what
I was supposed to do.
And so I was driving to the radio station.
My opponent had over $20,000,
I had less than $800.
As I was in the radio station,
the guy said, "You're going
to make a commercial?"
I said, "Yes."
He said, "It better be a good one,
"because that money can't
go pretty far here."
(laughter)
And I sat there in the
middle of the control room
and I was thinking.
And here's what happens
when you get still:
Stuff will start coming.
Something said, "Call your mama.
"You used to talk about your
mother on the air all the time.
"Ask her to say a few words for you.
"That'll be a different
kind of political spot."
(laughter)
So I called my mama.
And I had a gospel record
playing in the background.
(laughter and applause)
(Les laughs)
And then I had my mother say,
"Hello, this is Mrs. Mamie Brown.
"When I raised my sons, I
raised them to be good children.
"When they got out of hand,
"I'd beat their behind
and made 'em go right.
"Please vote for my son, he's a good boy."
(laughter and applause)
Usually in a State Representative race,
maybe 3 or 4,000 people will
come out to vote in a primary.
In that primary race, over
27,000 people came out and voted,
said, "I'm voting for Les Brown,
"'cause his mama say he's a good boy."
(laughter)
I won, ladies and gentlemen!
I won!
(applause)
So you've got to be
willing to stay focused,
to be creative, to be relentless.
Because things are going to happen to you
when you're working on your dream.